- "And in the last days,
it shall be God declares
"that 'I will pour forth
out my spirit
upon all flesh and your sons,
and your daughters'"...
- This is it. Nice shoes.
- "'Who came up against some'"--
- Thank you
for your loss.
- Is this seat taken?
I like your shoes.
They're very nice.
- I'm ecstatic
for your loss.
- You need to be quiet.
- Is one of you
Genevieve Russell?
- Oh, that's totally me.
The priest knows my name.
How cool is that?
How'd you know?
- Because this ceremony
ended 15 minutes ago,
and we've been waiting
for a Genevieve Russell
to deliver the final eulogy.
- Oh, shoot.
Okay, yeah. Coming.
Where's the thing?
- What thing?
- [whispers] The paper.
The eulogy. Where is it?
- I don't have it.
I don't have it. Just wing it.
- I can't.
- Just wing it.
- I'm not gonna wing it.
I'm not a bird.
- Then do it. Go, go.
- [whispering] All right.
What's wrong with your voice?
Why can't you whisper?
- I don't know. I don't know.
- Hey, you're the truck
driver guy, right?
You're the guy
that killed Chet?
- Yes.
I'm so sorry
for your loss.
- Oh, that's okay, man.
Hey, I, uh--
can I ask you a question?
Were you scared?
Did he scare you,
even a bit?
- He scared the [bleep]
out of me.
- Yeah.
[chuckles]
Yeah, he did.
- Ma'am?
- Coming.
- Whoo! Yay, Gene.
Yay, Ge--
- Okay.
That's enough, Billie.
Hey, everybody.
How's it going?
Um, sorry I'm late.
Not the sort of thing
you want to hurry up and get to,
am I right?
- [laughs]
- [clears throat]
Chet Bingham
was a maker of apps
and a lover of shadow
government conspiracy theory.
He was my friend,
and I, uh...
I don't have
a lot of those,
so losing one
is really hard.
He--he was a...
Sorry.
He was a...
[speaks gibberish]
Yeah.
He was a...
[speaking gibberish]
[speaks gibberish]
[gasps]
To know!
He was a...
[speaking gibberish]
- Okay.
- What I'm trying to say is...
[speaking gibberish]
- Excuse me.
Excuse me.
Move, sir. Please.
I got this.
- [speaking gibberish]
- Okay.
- [speaks gibberish]
- [mouths words]
- I'm sorry.
I feel like an idiot.
Move your Bible.
- Move your Bible.
- Jesus.
Hold this with your--
- What?
- Hold it with
your holy hands.
[clears throat]
I have never seen anyone
try and evade the pain of loss
as much as this woman
has today.
- What's up?
- Is it
because she's a bad person?
- Yes.
- No. Is it because
she has the maturity
of a Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle,
a TMNT?
No.
It is because her heart
is as big as Chet's head
in this poster behind me,
which, if I am not mistaken,
has been sneaking up
this whole time
trying to push me in the coffin!
- What? No.
- No, sir! You won't have me!
- No. Billie. Someone. Someone.
- Stop it!
- Get her off of there!
- You will never--
- Get her off. Don't--
- Billie.
- I'll kill you!
- Billie!
- [screaming]
- Get off of him!
- You're not gonna
take me with you!
- Get off of him.
- I'm embarrassed.
I'm embarrassed now,
please.